ORDER AND GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN. TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC OUR
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
ARE LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HEARING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND OUR FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND TO
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES SO THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. ARE
ALL OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WILL BE PARTICIPATING DIRECTLY
NOT REMOTELY. SO BUT FOR THE
PUBLIC. WE HAVE THE ABILITY FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE ACTUALLY
PHYSICALLY IN THE ROOM TO
TESTIFY AND THEN WE ARE SO WE
HAVE THIS HEARING ROOM IN
ANOTHER WE ALSO ALLOW
TESTIMONY BY TELEPHONE AND WE
HAVE A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. SO THE NOT THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER. AN ACCESS CODE THAT YOU
WOULD USE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE BUT LET ME
READ IT NOW IT WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. THAT
NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
SIX ONE THREE FOUR FOUR ONE
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO. FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. YOU PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND YOU WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND AT
THAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTED
AND YOU CAN ADDRESS OUR
COMMITTEE. AND. PRIOR TO IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL BE
MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING IS. AND ANYONE WHO'S
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARING
SINCE CLOSE THIS MANNER. AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. DUE TO THE PHONE IN
TECHNOLOGY AND FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW TOOLS
SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE TWO BILLS THAT
WE WERE HERE TODAY- BILL AB
FIFTEEN OR SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY. AND
BILL AB TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO.
THEM BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION THE BILLS I'VE GOT
A QUORUM NOW SO LET'S SAY A
ESTABLISH THEIR QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SKINNER. FIVE HERE I'M HERE
SURE A LOT RESIDENT MOORLACH
PRESENTS BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE
JACKSON JACKSON HERE JACKSON
HERE MITCHELL. MORALE WIENER
WIENER PRESENTS MCCARTY. ALL
RIGHTS RESERVED ARE CORN AND-
LET US BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
BILL PRESENTATION AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY YOU HAVE THE.
THE PARTY OF. THANK YOU SENATOR%
SKINNER AND THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS BILL
TODAY AND FOR WORKING WITH US
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS AND
FRANKLY- YEARS ON THIS ISSUE
THIS IS THE THIS IS THE THIRD
TIME I PRESENTED THIS BILL IN
THE LEGISLATURE SO IT'S NOT A
NEW TOPIC YOU KNOW WE SPENT A
LOT OF WORK IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS AS FAR AS POLICE REFORM
IN TRYING TO PREVENT A DEADLY
FORCE WITH THE CIVILIANS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT THIS BILL
IS IN THE RARE INSTANCE WHERE
THERE IS AN INCIDENT OF THE
FORCE THERE IS ROUGHLY. ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
PER YEAR PAST THREE YEARS AS
FAR AS BRINGING ABOUT MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AFTER THE FACT
AND- AS WE KNOW THE CURRENT
PROCESS HAS THE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DO THE INVESTIGATION
AND NUMBER GOING TO FROM MY
WITNESS NEPHEW SECOND ST FROM
ACROSS THE NATION THAT PROCESS
IS JUST ROCK WITH WOULD
CONFLICT THERE MAYBE NOT A
LEGAL AND ETHICAL CONFLICT BUT
THERE'S AN ABSOLUTE PERCEIVED
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AND IS
JUST TOO MUCH. DISTRUST IN
ESSENTIALLY POLICE POLICE
THEMSELVES WITH A LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THERE IS A
BETTER WAY- THERE ARE FIVE
STATES IN OUR NATION THAT HAVE
TO LAUNCH THIS EFFORTS- IT'S
NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE THE FIRST
STATE THAT DID THIS BY THE WAY
WAS WAS WISCONSIN WAS GOVERNOR
SCOTT WALKER AND THAT WAS
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S HE'S REFORM
COMMISSION ANY FOR THREE
RECOMMENDED THE- PARTY A FROM
DOWN OUT AND JOAQUIN ISSUE
ATTORNEY RACE CAR BURKE. ASKED
THIS FOR LAW CENTER TWO IN AND
LOOK AT THE SAYS FOR THE
INVESTIGATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DEADLY FORCE
AND CIVILIANS AND THEY CAN THE
CONCLUSION THE KERN SYSTEM JUST
ONE THAT IS ABOUT TOO MUCH TO.
LOW POLICE TO IS SEGMENTS SO WE
BE DAY IS PROCESS WHERE WE CAN
A STATE. A SECURE A STEP UP IN
IN CERTAIN. AT DO THIS DO THE
WORK YEAH I'VE BEEN YOU KNOW
ALSO I WANT TO STATE BUT THE
GET GO AND SHE ONE X. THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU. HAVE
OUTLINED IN NOVELS FOR
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND YOU
KNOW THIS WILL BRING ABOUT
MORE- TRANSPARENCY AND TRUST IN
THE PROCESS. AND ESSENTIALLY WE
WILL HAVE A UNIT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THE INVESTIGATION
AND POTENTIALLY THE PROSECUTION
THE RARE INSTANCE WHERE THERE
IS. A WARRANT FOR PROSECUTION-
WE WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT ADVOCATES BACK
AND FORTH- I WILL KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A- A LIVING
BREATHING PROCESS WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY OR
ENGAGING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE REFUSING WITH
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SO. I
WOULD HAVE THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE OVER THE COMING WEEKS
AND- WITH THAT I WOULD ASK MY
WITNESSES TO- TO PRESENT. AND
CERTAINLY WANT TO ENGAGE WITH
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL A
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NOW
BEFORE WE GO TO THE KEY WITNESS
JUST TO REMIND FOLKS THAT WE
WILL HAVE. THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WHO WILL
HAVE. THANK ME TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES. AND THEN WE WILL. OPEN
THE PHONE LINES AND I SAY WILL
OPEN THE PHONE LINES BECAUSE
WHAT WOULD WILL ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE ROOM BUT IT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE SOMEONE IN
THE ROOM AT THE MOMENT BUT WE
WILL ASK THAT THEN WE WILL OPEN
THE PHONE LINES IN THE-
OPERATOR. MODERATOR WILL. GIVE
THOSE WHO'VE CALLED IN THE
INSTRUCTIONS BUT FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WANT TO CALL IN AND
SUPPORT. BY YOU WILL. THE
NUMBER I READ YOU CAN ALSO SEE
IT ON THE- COMMITTEE ON.
WEBSITE SO THE- THE MAIN
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS BIG- NOT-
SKEWS ME IS CHRISTIAN AT ABRAMS
WHO IS SOLANO CITY DA.
CHRISTIAN ABRAMS BATTLER
MIGRATION AGENCY WHAT. OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HI MY
NAME IS CHRIS ABRAMS ON THE
DISK TWENTY FIRST LANA COUNTY
AND I'VE BEEN A CREEK
PROSECUTOR FOR ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AS THE ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF SOLANO
COUNTY I STRONGLY SUPPORT
pASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OF SIX
THE NATIONAL NARRATIVE
REGARDING OFFICER INVOLVED
FATAL INCIDENT SINCE BEEN A
PRIMARY CONCERN FOR CITIZENS OF
SPAWNING COUNTY FOR QUITE SOME
TIME WE HAD THIRTY SIX OFFICER
INVOLVED THE TALLADEGA LAST
THIRTEEN YEARS BUT OVER THE
LAST YEAR WE'VE HAD TO HAVE
TORN APART THE VERY FABRIC OF
OUR COMMUNITY. AFTER BOB
SHOOTINGS BY THEIR NATURE ARE
EMOTIONALLY CHARGED BUT THE TWO
MOST RECENT HAVE RAISE THE
ANGER FRUSTRATION AND TENSION
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO LEVEL
WE HAVE NOT WITNESSED BEFORE.
OUR OFFICES RECEIVED OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND EMAILS
AND PHONE CALLS SINCE JUNE.
DEMANDING JUSTICE IN THESE
CASES. GIVEN THE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE HISTORY OF
LOCAL HIGH PROFILE OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. AND THE
COMPLETE BREAKDOWN OF TRUST
BETWEEN COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
THAT POLICE DEPARTMENT. MY
EXECUTIVE TEAM BELIEVE THESE
TWO CASES SHOULD BE HANDLED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
THE CALLS FOR AN INDEPENDENT
ARM'S-LENGTH INVESTIGATION
REVIEW. NOT JUST LIMITED TO THE
FAMILIES OF SHOT MONTERROSA AND
MOLLY MCCOY THERE'S BEEN A
TIDAL WAVE OF PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC FIGURES INCLUDING
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LEADERS LOCAL
AND STATE OFFICIALS. AND THE
MEDIA CALLING FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT REVIEW. OUR OFFICE
HAS LISTENED TO THE CONCERNS
THE COMMUNITY DUE TO THE
PERCEPTION BY MANY OF A
PERCEIVED CONFLICT IT APPEARED
NECESSARY AND APPROPRIATE IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST. THE
ATTENDANT ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
BE INVOLVED TO PROVIDE THE
CONFLICT FREE AND INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT DESERVE. THEREFORE
WE REACHED OUT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR ASSISTANCE AS WE
BELIEVE THIS OUTSIDE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW WOULD HELP.
PUBLIC IN THE FINAL DECISION. I
BELIEVE THAT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN AT SIX KAMBOJAS THE
GOAL OF INSTILLING THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE. AN IMPARTIAL OF THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS AND
AVOID ANY PERCEPTION OF BIAS OR
CONFLICT. I UNDERSTAND THAT
MONEY STAFFING AND RESOURCES
WILL BE A CONCERN AT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE WEE
TO HANDLE ALL OF THE OFFICER
ABOUT THE CALORIES. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT MANDATE THE AG DO
LL BUT ONLY AT THE REQUEST OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. AND I BELIEVE MANY
REVIEWS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
HANDLED BY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I'D SAY BERMAN
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE ANY TIME
FOR THE OTHER MAIN SUPPORT. YOU
SHOULD WRAP UP. OKAY WELL THEN
I'LL JUST WRAP UP THAT I
BELIEVE- AT THE HALF OF MY
COMMUNITY THAT I SERVE I DO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER MAIN
WITNESS IN SUPPORT YOU HAVE A
MINUTE. HELLO MY NAME IS RUSTY
CITY. AND I'M INSISTENCE DR
ALICE. PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S CAR. OFFICE OF THE
INTELLIGENCE. SHARING A CREDIT.
COURSE AB CREEK BAPTIST OH SIX
ANYWAY. GEORGE. OUR SERVICES IS
BY THE END LAW ENFORCEMENT IT
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE INTO
ENTRANCE. OVERSIGHT OF POLICE
FOR ANSWERING TO REGAIN ITS IN
AFTERNOON COMMUNITIES CHURCH
TRUCKS CAN ONLY BE A- BY TRAINS.
ALTERNATE THERE PARTY
SPECIALIZED IN THESE. IT IS
IMMEDIATE MAKES JUSTICE IS TO.
IT IS NOT A FOR THE POLICE TO
POLICE THEM BECAUSE ALL TO OPT
THERE'S NO GESTURES BLACK AND
BROWN. ARE IS THIS YOUR READY
TO AB FIFTEEN POSTED FOR THE
FAMILY DRANK COMMUNITY WHO HAVE
LOST LOVED ONES AT THE HANDS OF
THE OF COURSE. OUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THOROUGH MARC YOU
CAN OF A NOW KEY UP WHO GOING
TO SPEAK IN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND THEN BEFORE WE EIGHT PLEASE
DO THAT AND ALSO I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO RE ALL OF US THE- OUR
FOR MASS ARE PROTECT US AND
ALSO OTHERS AND WE NEED TO WEAR
THEM ON OUR NOSE AND MOUTH SO
PLEASE OF THOSE OF US WHO MAY
THESE THINGS DO SLIP A SLIP
EASILY BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE
IF EVERYONE WOULD PLEASE MAKE
SURE THEIR MASK IS COVERING
YOUR NOSE. GO AHEAD MODERATOR.
HANDLEY'S JUDGMENT ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT.
AND AS OF RIGHT NOW- LOOKS LIKE
WE DO HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN THAT
ARE IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY GO AHEAD
WE WILL START WITH NUMBER
THIRTY NINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BRAMBELL CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. NEXT TO A NUMBER FORTY
SIX FORTY SIX PLEASE GO. G.
MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
FORTY IN SUPPORT. WE NEED.
BURGER KING FOR NEXT WILL GO TO
NUMBER FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND COMMITTEE AND
SHARED. THIS IS LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON. I AM SPEAKING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WE THE PEOPLE OF
SAN DIEGO. AND THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTH CALIFORNIA
INTO THANK YOU. NEXT SERVER
NUMBER FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JAMIE MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GAIL
STEWARD ON BEHALF OF THE SUMMER
STAFF AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT YEAR
THE NUMBER FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE FURTHER
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU.
NEKOGA NUMBER FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MA'AM TURN MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAU
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
COMMITTEE START BEYOND THE
HAPPY STUDENTS DEMAND ACTION
AND SUPPORT. NEXUS NUMBER FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. TIANA
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT TO ADELINE FIFTY SEVEN.
OVERS THE APPARENT RESIDENTS
SACRAMENTO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THE NEXT OVER THE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SUMMARY FROM MACULA AND THE
SURVIVOR WHERE EVERY TOWN MOMS
DEMAND ACTION AND I CAN REPORT.
NEXT TO THE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS TAMARA TOOK OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE HAVE NUMBER
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S TOWN HALL MY FROM A STOP
BY THE WOMAN WHICH APARTMENT
MILE CALL ON JUNE SECOND I'M
SUPPORT. ANYONE CAN LAYS IN
GERMAN ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
THE KEY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THREE HAVE THOSE- KEY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. YES
YOUR THAT VEHICLE DIRECTOR OF
COURAGE YOU DIS UNITED FOR SORT
OF THE JUSTICE. MADAM CHAIR
COMMAND CHOIR FOR JUGGLER POINT
CLARIFICATION IT IS THIS- OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS
AMENDED. OKAY ESTIMATED SO
MAYBE I JUST NEED TO QUICKLY.
HERE ARE JUST AS WELL AS THE
SUPPORT SO- LET ME QUICKLY
OUTLINED THAT AN APOLOGIES MR
GOVE AS WE'LL GET RIGHT BACK TO
THAT. WILL ALLOW YOU AND
WHOEVER ELSE IS LEAD OPPOSITION
TO HAVE YOUR THREE MINUTES AND
THEN TAKE OTHERS SO THE BILL
WAS ORIGINALLY STRUCTURED WELL
I DON'T KNOW FOR REGIONALLY BUT
THE BILL THAT WAS BEFORE US
HAD- HAD INVESTIGATION.
REQUIRED IF A TEACHER IF A. D.
A. POLICE AGENCY REQUESTED IT.
AND THAT WHILE I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT IS THAT THERE ARE
THOSE TWO CATEGORIES ARE
LEGITIMATE REQUESTERS FOR SUCH
INVESTIGATION THEY'RE CERTAINLY
NOT THE ONLY AND THAT IF WE
WERE TO PROCEED WITH A BILL
THAT MANDATED. ONLY
INVESTIGATIONS WITH BY THE
REQUEST OF DA'S OR- A LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEIR- PEOPLE
WITH THEIR COULD BE SHOOTINGS
THAT SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED
THAT WOULD NOT BE AND
ADDITIONALLY WE MAY BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THE STATE IS
USING RESOURCES FOR AN
INVESTIGATION THAT THE LOCALITY
POTENTIALLY COULD OF
INVESTIGATED BUT IS- THEN THE
IN FACT THERE. ARE THEY ARE
SHOOTING THE COST THE STATE SO
IT THE R. INTENT OF THE
AMENDMENTS WAS NUMBER ONE TO
ENSURE. THAT AL DEATHS OF
UNINFORMED THE CIVILIANS BE
INVESTIGATED SO THAT IS TO PUT
THAT IS RIGHT NOW IN THERE THAT
ALL REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
ANYONE STASHED THAT THEY WOULD-BE INVESTIGATED THEN
SECONDARILY. THE INCLUSION OF
THE GOVERNING BODY OF THE
JURISDICTION SO A COUNTY BOARD
OF SOUPS OR CITY COUNCIL. COULD
VOTE TO ASK FOR AN
INVESTIGATION NOT JUST THE DA'S
OR POLICE AGENCIES. SO THAT IS
HOW THE BILL'S STRUCTURED NOW
THAT RATHER THAN IT'S USING THE
TERMINOLOGY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SERVICES STATE
PROSECUTOR NOTE THE MOM. THERE
STATE PROSECUTOR IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SO UNLESS
THERE'S SOME A FUTURE ACTION IT
WOULD BE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE HOWEVER. WHAT THE BILL
ALLOWS FOR IS. BECAUSE IF THIS
POLICY MOVES. WE WON'T BE
THERE'S A COST TO THIS POLICY
SO ASSUMING THAT IT MOVES.
THERE WILL HAVE TO BE AN
APPROPRIATION IN THE FUTURE
BUDGET. AND AT THAT POINT. THE
ISSUES OF. WHO THAT STATE
PROSECUTOR IS AND HOW IT IS
CONSTITUTED. AND WHAT ITS
STAFFING IS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS CAN BE WORKED OUT. IN
THAT APPROPRIATIONS SO THAT IS
THE BILL AS AMENDED THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US SO IT BROADENS.
WHAT THE INVESTIGATIONS ARE BY
MAKING SURE THAT INVESTIGATIONS
OF ALL UNARMED DEATHS OF
UNARMED. IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR
INVESTIGATION THAT ARE
REQUESTED BY MORE THAN JUST DE
ACER POLICE AGENCIES. AND
SPECIFIES IT IS A STATE
PROSECUTOR SO THAT. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WAS
THERE ANY THING THAT I
CHARACTERIZED IN TERMS OF YOUR
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS THAT WAS
INACCURATE NOW THAT THERE IS
ONE OTHER ONE WITH WHICH WHICH
WAS THAT YOUR SUGGESTION WHICH
I THINK IS IMPORTANT YES.
POTENTIALLY HAVING A
REIMBURSEMENT FROM A LOCAL
ENTITY THAT WE NEEDED I THINK
SORT OUT SOME LIKE LOS ANGELES
WE HEARD FROM THE TESTIMONIES
OF DIFFERENT BUDGET THEN. THE
COUNTY OF ALPINE IN SELF YOU
KNOW THE MAY BE APPROPRIATE TO
HAVE SOME TYPE OF A MATCH. A
COPAY PER SE THAT SO HOW THE
BILLS AND READ IT IT ALLOWS US
TO ATTEMPT TO DO SO BUT IT
DOESN'T MANDATE WHAT THAT
AMOUNT WOULD BE IT USES THE
WORD MAY NOT SHALL. OKAY SO.
WITH THAT AND ALLOW US TO. OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BEGIN
OPPOSITION- MR GARBER'S DO WANT
TO START. YES SO THANK YOU-
WELL THOSE AMENDMENTS SOUND
PROMISING THE LANGUAGE IS STILL
VERY BIG SO ONCE FINAL
LANGUAGES IN PRINT AND IT'S
REALLY TRULY CLEAR THAT- THIS
IS GONNA BE A AN AUTHENTICALLY
INDEPENDENT- PROSECUTOR AND
IT'S NO LONGER- GAME OF POLICE
POLICING THEMSELVES. AND ALL
THOSE OTHER TOPICS OF INTEREST
AND WE COULD POTENTIALLY
SUPPORT BUT WE'D LIKE TO BE A
PART OF REVIEWING THAT LANGUAGE
IN A PART OF THE WORKING OUT
THOSE DETAILS. SO UNTIL THAT
TIME WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ONTHE
RECORD. SAYING THAT COMMUNITY
FOR SORT OF YOU JUSTICE. AND
YOU KNOW ONE ORGANIZATION IT
WORKS DIRECTLY WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS WHOSE LOVED ONES HAVE
BEEN STOLEN. BY POLICE. AND
MANY OF US ARE FORMING A CAR
SHOULD LEADERS WHO ARE
SURVIVORS OF STATE VIOLENCE. IT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON AB FIFTEEN OH SIX. WE WANT
TO BE AMENDED TO CREATE A TRULY
INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR TO
HANDLE POLICE ABUSE CASES IN
CALIFORNIA. FIRST YOU HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO OPERATE
INDEPENDENTLY FROM ANY LOCAL DA
OFFICE AND FROM THE CHINESE
GENERAL ATTORNEY GENERAL'S THE
TOP COP. AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND SO- THE OTHER
ISSUE IN LANGUAGE- THAT WE
HAVE. IS THAT EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH
SIX DOES NOT GIVE THE VICTIMS
AND THE FAMILIES OF VICTIMS
ANYTHING TO PROSECUTE WHOSE.
RECENT THE EXCLUSIVELY OF THIS
ISN'T AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM AND WHAT FAMILIES DO
NOT TRUST THE PROCESS. SO LIKE
TO GO ON RECORD OF SAYING THAT
WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. WE
ARE REQUESTING TO BE A PART OF
REVIEWING- THE LANGUAGE AND
DETAILS OVER THE NEXT WEEK OR
SO AND BEING A PART OF WORKING
OUT THE DETAILS THOSE WHO
ACROSS THE PAIN. ARE CLOSE TO
THE SOLUTION WHEN THE EXPECTED
FOR ALL MODELS IN THIS CAN'T
JUST BE ANOTHER BACKROOM DEAL
DEAL BECAUSE- HE LIVES ARE
SACRED. BUT US TO GET OUT OF IT
SO. WE'RE ASKING THAT WILL BE
INCLUDED IN. THIS PROCESS Q. I.
WE I SHOULD HAVE TO PUT I DID
NOT SAY HE COULD NOT SEE
HERNANDEZ ARE YOU ON LINE. I AM
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU CAN BE BRIEF
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT. I
APPRECIATE NOT SERVE HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION COMPLEX
EMPLOYERS WE DID COME INTO THE
HEARING TODAY WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
LANGUAGE OF THE AMENDMENT.
THANK IN THE CORRECT DIRECTION-
OUR POSITION IS THAT THERE DOES
NEED TO BE VERY SPECIFIC
INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR CREATED.
BEFORE WE NEED AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW FOR. A COLLABORATION
WITH THE INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTOR. SIMILAR TO THE
CONNECTICUT MODEL THAT WAS JUST
ADOPTED BUT WE COULD GO- THAT
IS WHAT WE THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
BUT WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT IN
THE BAY AREA FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S BEEN ONE PROSECUTION.
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS IN LA THERE'S
BEEN ONE IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS. THE CURRENT APPROACH IS
NOT WORKING. I THINK THAT THERE
ARE CHEN. IN GIVING IT TO THE
CHEN. I'M NOT BEING THE ONLY
OPTION. WE DO BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE TO PURSUE A MORE
INDEPENDENT BOTTLE I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK
ON THE ISSUE. COMMITMENT HERE.
OUR THAT. IS OUR POSITION RIGHT
NOW I. AFTER ALL ADDED I'VE
WORKED ON THE SHIP OF IN THE
CAPITAL. WELCOME FOR THE CALL.
NIGHT THERE YOU'RE AGO THE
FRIEND OF A CREEPY CAL FIVE FOR
REVIEW IN YOU'LL WANT THAT.
THEY'RE YEAR WAITING VERY
STRONG YOU CAN BE AND I'D
REALLY DON'T WANT TO WAY
ANOTHER YEARS. SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE ON THE STOCK
TODAY AND THE FORWARD TO SEEING
ON THE LINE TO DO FOR HAVING
YOUR OUT. TRIGGERED TO THE
INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR WELL
THANK YOU. I'M NOW MODERATE IF
YOU COULD QUEUE UP THE-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND SO
EVERYONE NOW WAS CALLING IT
WILL BE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION HOWEVER. BUT THERE
WAS LATE OPPOSITION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO WHOEVER THE
FIRST LAW ENFORCEMENT CALLERS I
WILL GIVE A MINUTE SO.
MODERATOR GO AHEAD. IN LATE IN
GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF ABFIFTEEN OH SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN. ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AS OF NOW WE DO
HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN OUR QUEUE
OKAY. I WILL START WITH NUMBER
FORTY NINE NUMBER FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CORY
SUBZERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- WE HAD COME INTO
THIS- DAY OR YESTERDAY WITH A
WATCH POSITION ON THE BILL I WE
WERE NOT OPPOSED GIVEN THE
AMENDMENTS WE RECEIVED LATE
YESTERDAY UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR
WE ARE NOW IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IT SUFFERS FROM
SIGNIFICANT POLICY AND
PROCEDURAL CHALLENGES. IT
BYPASSES LOCAL INVESTIGATORY
PROCESSES INCLUDING ESTABLISHED
AGREEMENTS TO HAVE OUTSIDE
AGENCIES INVESTIGATE OFFICER
INVOLVED USE OF FORCE.
ADDITIONALLY IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER A STATE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATION REQUIRED BY THIS
BUT WOULD AKE THE PLACE OF A
BE IN ADDITION TO A LOCAL
INVESTIGATION WHICH ALLOWING
CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REQUEST
INVESTIGATIONS. SHE SACRAMENTO.
THE SITE IS DIFFICULT. THEY'RE
ALREADY SUBJECT TO A VERY HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW AT MULTIPLE
LEVELS. THE BILL INCLUDES NO
DIRECTION OR REQUIREMENT THAT
AN ENTITY THAT REQUEST
INVESTIGATION BE GEOGRAPHICALLY
PROXIMATE OR SHARE SOME LEVEL
JURISDICTION FOR EXAMPLE IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED THE CITY
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. GET OUT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE AN INCIDENT
INVOLVING A DEPUTY SHERIFF A
BAY AREA COUNTY. AG IS NOT
RESOURCE- EQUIPPED TO TAKE ON
THE DUTIES CONTEMPLATED BY THIS
BILL IN THE LOCAL REIMBURSEMENT
LANGUAGE IS INSUFFICIENT. BILLS
ALSO INCREASED LOCAL EVEN
DEEPER INVESTIGATION THE
REQUESTING AGENCY OR THE AGENCY
APPLYING THE OFFICER INVOLVED
IN THE INCIDENT. IN THE CASE OF
AN INVESTIGATION MANDATED BY
THIS BILL IN A SITUATION WHERE
THE LOCAL AGENCY CONDUCTS AN
INVESTIGATION THE LOCAL AGENCY
COULD END UP FOR TO
INVESTIGATION. THE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY ISSUES INCLUDING THOSE
NOTED ABOVE AND THE PROCESS OF%
CHALLENGING. CONSIDERING THIS
VERY SERIOUS MATTER AT THE END
OF A TRUNCATED LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WITH VERY LITTLE
OFFICIAL REVIEW WE MUST ADDRESS
UNFORTUNATELY. THE FIFTEEN OH
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARI.
NOW EVERY ELSE OF A- THE- IF
JUST NAME AND- YOUR
ORGANIZATION. THE NEXT WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER THIRTY ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTERRES ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
CLEAR INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR
AND WE WILL ALSO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENT LANGUAGE. PEAK OF
CALIFORNIA BASED IN ACTION
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM SANTA CRUZ
BIOCEUTICALS. BUT YOU KNOW
EQUITY ADVOCACY POLICY
INSTITUTE. LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALL OF
US ARE NONE OF US. OTHER THAN
FAMILY THE SAMPLE. LOVELOCK
BLOOD CAMPAIGN. THERE'S A
STRAIN YOU JUSTICE COALITION
BLIND BEAUTIFICATION MOVEMENT.
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES PROTESTED
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE. HI
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR LINES OPEN.
THANK YOU ERIC SCHWEITZER
TOURNEY PRIVATE PRACTICE FRESNO
CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO A
TRULY INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF THE NUMBER
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS. CALLING FROM COMMUNITY
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND I
TOLD UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THAT BY
CHANCE THE COMMUNITIES DENIED
AT FOUR THIRTY IT'S JUST THAT
SOME COLLEGE FOOTBALL AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX UNLESS I MEANT
THAT I TO CREATE AN INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION AN INDEPENDENT.
PROSECUTOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT TO A NUMBER THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER
THIRTY SIX OF THESE MAKE SURE
NOT ON MUTE. EIGHT BUT HE
CUTTING FROM COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND I
OPPOSE AND LESS THE DEMANDED
CREATE AN INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION WITH A INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTOR. AND ONE MORE
REMINDER LAYS JOHN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU WHAT'S
THE OPEN IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE. A SENATOR JACKSON
THANK YOU A I'M TO CLEAR ON
WHAT WHERE THE BILL IS AT THE
MOMENT BECAUSE- I THINK THE
OPPOSITION. HAS INDICATOR LEE
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION'S
INDICATED THAT PERHAPS THESE
AMENDMENTS WORK IN THE AND
PERHAPS THEY'RE NOT FAR ENOUGH
SO IF WITH THE COURT WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR- THIS A
MEASURE REQUIRES A STATE
PROSECUTOR. TO INVESTIGATE IN
FLORIDA FORSMAN TO SERVE FORCE
AGAINST UNARMED CIVILIANS
RESULTING IN DEATH SO IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE A DIRECTIVE IF YOU
HAVE AN UNARMED PERSON WHO HAS
BEEN KILLED AT THE HANDS OF
POLICE. INVESTIGATE PLEASE YES-
CRICKET CLARIFICATION. I DON'T
THINK YOU SHOULD USE THE WORD
INDEPENDENT THERE BECAUSE IT
COULD BE. BUT THIS IS THE WAY
IT'S WRITTEN DOES NOT GUARANTEE
IT IF WE IF WE VIEW FOUR IF THE
VIEW IS THAT AN INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTOR IS A PROSECUTOR
OFFICE THAT IS A SPECIALLY
ESTABLISHED FOR THIS PURPOSE.
AND NOT HOUSED WITHIN AN
EXISTING LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICE
OKAY THEN IT CREATES THAT
POSSIBILITY BUT IT DOES NOT
INSURE ALL RIGHT SO WHAT I'M
SAYING INDEPENDENT I'M ASSUMING
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS AN
INDEPENDENT AGENCY WHAT ARE
WHAT I HEAR BEING SAID IS THAT
ISN'T NECESSARILY THE CASE OR
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY. ASSUME
THAT THE AG'S INDEPENDENT IS
THAT CORRECT IN OTHER WORDS
WE'RE LOOKING AT POTENTIALLY
SETTING UP. AN ENTIRELY NEW
BODY. THAT BE DEEMED END OF
PROSECUTOR. OR WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS AN INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR
BECAUSE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
SUPPOSED TO STEP IN- TWO
SITUATIONS WHERE. THERE IS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BY IN A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MOST
OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE COMES
IS SUPPOSED TO BE DONE. COUNTY
WIDE AND IN THE CONTROL OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF THAT
COUNTY SO. BOB THERE'S A
QUESTION HERE APPARENTLY ABOUT
WHETHER THE AG IS DEEMED
INDEPENDENT OR WHETHER WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS AN
ENTIRELY SEPARATE ENTITY. THAT
PROBABLY DOESN'T YET EXIST SIDE
CORRECT. NOT TO CONFUSE THINGS
BUT IF YOU'RE FROM THE OP.
THERE'S KIND OF GROUPS THERE
THERE'S THE LAWN FOR. THE V.
OPPOSITE. AND THERE ARE SOME OF
THAT SOCIAL JUSTICE GROUPS IS
DON'T THINK THE GENERAL OR
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IS A PENNANT
INDEPENDENT OFF IN THE FIRST
PLACE. I THINK IT'S INDEPENDENT
BECAUSE IT'S SEPARATE FROM THE
LOCAL DETACHMENT SO THE POSTAL
SANTA BARBARA. THUS WOULD HAVE
IT WOULD BE AN OUT. AND DO IT
OUTSIDE LOCAL D. WERE THE CO.
AND KIND OF POLICE ITSELF SO I
VIEW IT AS AS IN THE- SO WHAT
THE MY PROBLEM IS OUT TO VOTE
SOMETHING I WANT TO BE CLEAR
WHAT IT IS THAT WE'RE BEING
ASKED TO VOTE ON RIGHT SO AS
THE AS THE BILL WAS AMENDED THE
FOR AMENDMENT. IT'S CLEAR I
IT'S WE TO OUT THE WORD
ATTORNEY AND WE PUT A THE WORK
STATE PROP. WHICH IS AS THE
CHAIR NOTED IN REALITY THE
PROXY FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BECAUSE OF ALL IS ONE STATE
FIND AND UNLESS SOMETHING ELSE
IS A STAFFERS. OKAY SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW IT
WOULD BE TO ATTORNEY. BUT NOT
NECESSARILY IF THERE IS IN FACT
THE CREATION OF SOME OTHER.
INDEPENDENT QUOTE UNQUOTE STATE
PROSECUTOR DEAD AT THIS POINT
TIME DOES NOT AND- ALL RIGHT SO
AND THAT WOULD THE CASE- IN A
TWO INVESTIGATE LONG. USE OF
FORCE AGAINST AN UNARMED
CIVILIAN. RESULTING IN DEATH.
IT ALLOW. LAWN FOR AGENCIES AND
THIS TO AND OTHERS WOULD I
ASSUME AYE THE DISH THE SUPER
BORED SUPER OR CITY COUNCIL TO
REQUEST THE ATTORNEY OFFICE
INVESTIGATE SO THE INDEPENDENT
STATE PROSECUTOR OKAY TO
REQUEST THE STATE PROSECUTOR
WHICH STILL AT THIS POINT TIME
IS CAG BUT IT COULD BE SOMEBODY
ELSE TO INVESTIGATED ALLOWS
THEM. TWO A SENSUALLY RETAIN
THIS INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR IT
COULD BE AT THE REQUEST OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR SOME OTHER ENTITY
DO WE KNOW WHAT OTHER ENTITY
THAT WOULD BE EASILY STREET
IT'S SPECIFIC IT'S WOULD ONLY
BE. ARE THE ADDITIONS ARE.
FACED A GOVERNING BODY. THE
GOVERNMENT BODY OKAY
JURISDICTION THE GOVERNING
JURISDICTION OF THE AGENCY THAT
EMPLOYED THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL FOR WHICH THE- SHOULD
THE DEATH OCCURRED. AND THEN SO
THAT THAT. A FLEXIBILITY IF IT
WAS AN ARM TO CONTACT AND THE-
LAW ENFORCEMENT ENDED UP WITH
OTHER DEATH OF THE PURPORTEDLY
ARM. UP PERPETRATOR RIGHT OKAY
AND THEN IF EITHER OF THOSE TWO
IT WILL ALLOW THE PROCESS WHO
AT THIS POINT IS BUT IT COULD
SOMEBODY TO SEE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT INVESTIGATION AND THEY
COULD SEE IT FROM THE
JURISDICTION THAT THEY HAVE.
TAKEN OVER AND THE INVESTOR ON
BEHALF OF. SECRETARY WRECKED
AND THAT'S THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE US TODAY. YES OKAY
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU I
JUST HAD A QUESTION A COMMENT
WE HAVE A AND I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THIS WAS PROVIDED BY
THE COMMITTEE OR NOT BUT I
FOUND IT VERY INTERESTING THAT
THE STATISTICS ON THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE SHOT TO DEATH BY POLICE
IN THE UNITED STATES FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY BY RACE. AND THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF DEATHS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WAS NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN. THEN IN. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINE NINETY SIX THAN
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO THOUSAND
FOUR. AND IT TWENTY TOTAL
NUMBER OF POLICE. OR OR DEATHS
BY POLICE OFFICERS IS ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE. I MEAN THAT
IS A HUGE REDUCTION IS THAT AN
ACCURATE FIGURE. DO YOU KNOW. I
DON'T HAVE INFORMATION I GUESS
WAS IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE USE
HALF THE YEAR SO FAR TWENTY
TWENTY THAT OVER MAYBE THEY
WEREN'T ALL DOCUMENTED WHEN
THIS REPORT CAME OUT MEDIA
REPORT CAME OUT EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY. I COULD BE SO COULD BE
FOR HALF YEAR BUT IT'S STILL AS
STUNNING DIFFERENCE AND OF
COURSE THE NUMBERS ARE STILL ME.
A THOUSAND P. KILLED BY POLICE
OFFICERS IN THE UNITED STATES
IT'S A- A STUNNING NUMBER.
ARGUABLY THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
SOME KIND OF YOUKNOW- THAT
CONFLICT CONFLICT- AT THE LEVEL
OF YOU KNOW FIREARMS BEING.
OPPOSED TO A POISED IN SHOCK BY.
PERPETRATORS. AS WELL AS THE
POLICE AND I'M WONDERING. A IF
THE ACT GROW BY QUESTION REALLY.
DE WITH IF THAT IS THE NAY. I
HOME. POLICE ARE. WERE THE VIC.
OF THE SHOOTINGS HAS THAT
NUMBER GOING WAY UP. OR YOUR-
THE INOTES. ROOM PROVIDE
NUMBERS FOR CAL. NOT
NATIONALLY. SO I'M SORRY SO I'M
GOING TO I THINK MAYBE. YOUR
STAFF PROVIDED. IT I'M NOT SURE
THAT BE ALL RIGHT I GET THE
REASON FOR MY CALL WAS. YOU
KNOW WE KEEP THERE IF. REDUCE
THE FINE TO TURN. THAT YOU YOU
FIRST AND ASK QUESTIONS LATER
IS LAW ENFORCEMENT. THAT IF WE
CHANGE THE RULES SO WE'RE GOING
TO SEE MORE. OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SHOULD A
KILLED AND I WAS JUST WONDERING
GIVEN THE REDUCTION THE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF. FATALITIES AS A
RESULT OF THESE INTERACTIONS
WHETHER WE'VE SEEN IN A BIG
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
POLICE OFFICERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I'M ASSUMING
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT ANSWER. I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW BUT WHAT I
THINK THE BIGGER PICTURE IS
THAT. THESE NUMBERS HAVE GONE
DOWN IN CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE IT
WAS IN THE ONE FIFTIES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN IN THE YEAR
BEFORE. I WAS IN THE TWO
HUNDREDS. SO WE THIS IN THE
INSTANCE. WHERE THERE'S AN OP
WHERE THERE'S A- ATTORNEY LIKE
OUR- OUR WITNESS EARLY FROM
SOME. WHO ASKED PROSECUTOR
COMMENT AND STEP IN. AND DO THE
INVESTIGATION IT WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS FOR THAT. RIGHT SO ALL
RIGHT SO I MIGHT I GUESS MY
POINT THAT. HOPEFULLY WILL SEE
THE NUMBER OF THESE INCIDENTS
GO DOWN AND DOWN AND DOWN SO
THAT WERE ONLY. LOOKING AT A
VERY VERY FEW ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS- IS IT YOUR EXPECTATION.
THAT BECAUSE THERE WILL BE THE
RIGHT TO SEEK REIMBURSEMENT WE
WILL BE SEEING THE REQUEST MADE
IN THIS SORT OF DISCRETIONARY
BASIS WHEN THERE HAS BEEN-
ACTUALLY EIGHT KM- IN ARMS.
INTERACTION ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING THAT WE WILL SEE
THOSE AGENCIES- MAKE THE
REQUEST FOR AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE CONCERN THE
OPPOSITION THAT STILL EXISTS.
IS THAT THEY WANT TO UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS TO BE DONE-
BY A STATE PROSECUTOR. AND NOT
MAKE IT DISCRETIONARY I WOULD
ASSUME THERE MIGHT BE SOME
AGENCIES THAT WOULD SAY NO WE
CAN'T AFFORD IT YEAH SO IS THAT
IS THAT IN ANY WAY FACTORED IN
NOT THAT I'M SAYING THAT THAT
SHOULD BE A DETERMINANT BUT I'M
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF. WHAT
THIS BILL IS LIKELY TO
ACCOMPLISH YEAH I THINK AS A
CHIRLA TWO. WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATIONS BUT ALSO THIS IS
PURSUANT TO NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
AND GETTING IMPLEMENTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS SOME
IDEAS ABOUT THIS THERE ARE SOME
SPOTS. WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
DISINCENTIVE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO SAY HEY. THIS
CASE IS RIPPING OUR COMMUNITY
APART THERE'S SO MUCH DISTRESS
BE LIKE A STATE PROSECUTOR STEP
IN I WOULD NOTE THAT IN THE
HIGH PROFILE INCIDENT. IN
VALLEJO THE CITY OF VALLEJO
AFTER HAVING A BIZARRE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT REFUSED TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION SAID WE WANT TO
TAKE IT WILL PAY FOR IT. SO THE
CITY ACTUALLY SAID WE WILL PAY
FOR IT SO I KNOW THERE THERE IS
A PRECEDENT OF A LOCAL GUY
STEPPING UP AND SAYING. THEY
WOULD PARTICIPATE IN AND I
THINK IT'S TO BE AS FAR AS WHAT
THAT REIMBURSEMENT WOULD LOOK
LIKE IT WOULDN'T BE ALL OF IT
BUT MAYBE SOME TYPE OF A SHARED
AGREEMENT IS NOT UNREASONABLE.
THANK YOU AND I MIGHT INDICATE
MY STAFF HAS ADVISED ME THAT
THE NUMBERS I RECITED IT TO
COME FROM THE END OF LACI PEACH
SO THEY'RE NOT. OUT OF THIN AIR
BUT- THANK YOU FOR THAT. MS
MITCHELL. MITCHELL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR YOU KNOW MISSED
MCCARTY HAVE A VIEW OUTLINE IN
YOUR OPENING STATE HAVE WORKED
THIS IS IN THE BILL FOR YEARS
NOW SO I. IT KNOWLEDGE THAT IN
ONE COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS NOT BEEN A- ALL ONE
EIGHT NON THAT I AM A CO AUTHOR.
OF THE BILL AS IN. AND WHY
APPRECIATE THE NATURE AND TONE
OF THE AMENDMENT TO TAKE IT IN
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
YOU ARE REPUBLICANS. BY PRE.
SENATOR JACK TRYING TO WALK ALL
THROUGH. I'M NOT SURE THAT ALL
THOSE NOT. WERE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT'S BEFORE. ON THIS I THINK
MY CAN. ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
CHANGE OF THE CONTEXT TO A
STATE PROSECUTOR AND THIS
NOTION THAT THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING POTENTIAL IN THE
FUTURE. MY CONCERN WITH THIS
LANGUAGE IS THAT WE'RE NOT
SETTING POLICY IN PLACE TODAY
THAT CAN GO INTO EFFECT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND SET UP
A PROCESS BY WHICH WE ALL LIVE
BY. ALL I HAVE READ AND TALK TO
COLLEAGUES IN OTHER STATES LIKE
CONNECTICUT WHO WHO WHO WHO WHO
ARE STANDING UP IS INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATORS AND ARE FUNDING
IT- AND SOUL I KNOW THE LAST
FEW WEEKS THE SASH. IT CAN GET.
CHAOTIC MY WORD. BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
AREN'T SENDING. UP FOR FURTHER
DELAY FOR ACTION. THAT WHATEVER
WE PASSED THE POLICY WE COME UP
WITH- ON AS A GOAL FOR
PROCREATION THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT HAS A PLAN THAT IS
CLEAR TO EVERYONE WHAT IT'S
GOING TO BE. I HEAR OPPOSITION
ASKING FOR INDEPENDENT I HEAR I
SEE THIS LANGUAGE CHANGE TO A
STATE PROSECUTOR. I INTERPRET
THAT TO MEAN INDEPENDENT UNTIL
I HEARD MADAM CHAIR SAY WHAT
COULD BE THE AG ANSEL THAN THAT
SET ME BACK AND SO. I'M JUST
CONCERNED THIS FIELD LIKE A
REAL MOVE TARGET THAT IS JUST.
TOOLING ARE AND I. PARTICULARLY
THAT MY NAME IS ON IT WITH
MISTER I DO WANNA MAKE. THAT
IT'S SO THAT'S NOT. IN TERMS
OF. SETTING THIS ON A PATH THAT
IS CLEAR AND IDENTIFIED AND
FINITE. THE FOLLOWING. CAN YOU
DO A FIVE YEAH I GUESS THE BIG
PICTURE IS WHETHER IT WAS THE
VERSION THREE DAYS AGO OR THIS
ONE THE IT STILL WOULD HAVE TO
BE SUBJECT TO NEXT YEAR'S.
BUDGET AS FAR AS FINDING IT SO
IF THIS LAW BECOMES WAS SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR IN OCTOBER. IT
WOULD NECESSARILY HAVE ON
JANUARY ONE. THE CITY COUNCIL
OR- THE AIR CHIEF COULD CALL UP
AND SAY HEY. LET'S GO. WELL IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE FUNDED IN THE
BILL PURSUANT TO THE NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT SO. WITHOUT
THAT WERE ON THAT EITHER WAY.
AND SO THE HOW WOULD WE BECAUSE
WHETHER IS IN THE- HOW DEFINED
A STATE. SHALL I MEAN I I'M ON
COME WITH THE- LACK OF CLEAR
ABOUT WHETHER THE STATE
PROSECUTOR. IS THE AG OR
WHETHER OUR INTENT IS TO SET UP
SOMETHING INDEPENDENT IF WE
PASS THIS. SO ARE YOU SAYING
THEN THAT IT WILL SAY THAT THAT
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
ABOUT WHO THAT IS THEN
TRANSITIONS TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS. BUT THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT KIND OF I THINK
DECISION MAKING PROCESS IF WE
DECIDE WE'RE FUNDING THE AID
YOU TO DO THE WORK OR FOR
STANDING UP THE WHOLE
INDEPENDENT ENTITY. WE GOT THE
ALLUDED TO SHE OUTLINED THE
AMENDMENT IS DE FACTO THE STATE
PROSECUTOR BY DEFINITION IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL RIGHT OF THE
GOVERNOR THROUGH THE JAN TENTH
BUDGET PROCESS WITH OUR-
CONCURRENCE OF NEXT YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WANTS TO
HAVE. A SPECIAL. IN THE
ATTORNEY. OFFICE OUTSIDE YOU
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECT
WITH THE WHATEVER CALLED OVER
THERE THERE ARE MODELS THAT
SEEN IN. GOVERNMENT BUT RIGHT
BUT RIGHT NOW. THE DE FACTO
WOULD BE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS THE STATE PROSECUTOR IN
CALIFORNIA. IT AND I GUESS I'LL
JUST SAY IN CLOSING THAT THE I
DON'T KNOW IF THE LEGISLATURE
HAS LEFT. WHEN WE WILL BEHIND
AND TRIED TO DIVERT PA. I'M
JUST TRYING OF EXAMPLES WHERE
WE'VE LEFT. THE ULTIMATE.
BECAUSE THAT'S A PRETTY.
CRITICAL ELEMENT TO THIS UP TO
THE BUDGET PROCESS IN TERMS OF
WHETHER IT'S INTERNAL EXTERNAL.
AG NEW STAY PROP. FIVE THAT-
LEVEL OF I THINK LACK OF
CLARITY JUST GIVE ME SOME COUGH
ARE CONCERNED. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOU. FEDERAL ARE.
THANK YOU MANAGER I ALSO A FEW
KEY I. SENATOR JACK. PRESS
SEVEN MEMBERS THAT I DON'T HAVE
SIDE I JUST WANT TO CLEAR MY
YOU USED THE TERM WITH NO
WEAPON OR UNARMED THEY DIDN'T
HAVE IT IN MY- REAPING SO I'M
I'M JUST CURIOUS IS THERE A
DISTINCTION OR IS ANY POLICE
SHOOTING. WHERE SOMEONE IS BY.
KILLED WILL BE INVESTIGATED.
WITH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DO YOU WANT TO ANSWER THAT ARE
MAKING SHARE IT THE TO THE-
VERSION HAD. THE DEADLY FORCE
AT THE HANDS OF LINE FOR. A
LOCAL ENTITY SHARE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THE REQUEST TO GO TO THE AG'S
LAST PASS OF SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS UNDER THIS NOW ALL
ON ARM TO WHAT AUTOMATICALLY.
GET CHECKED OUT PER SE TO THIS
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT BUT
NOW. IN WHO WHO WHO ORANGE UP
WERE ARMED THAT WOULD STILL BE
AT THE DESK. OF THE LOCAL AND-
THE LOCAL DA THE TO SHERIFFS
ORDER GOT BODY PARTS OF SAID
COUNCIL. WHAT THE DISCRETION TO
ASK FOR THE INDEPENDENT
DESTINATION. WITH THE AT THE
STATE LEVEL. WHICH IS SORT OF
IN THE MODEL WE'VE HAD AND YEAH
CURRENT IT DOES HEARD FROM A
WITNESS USUALLY THE GENERAL
SAYS NOW. FOR THEM THE- YOU
COULD SAY THE DIFFERENCE.
CURRENT PRACTICE NOW IS THAT.
THE BILL'S WRITTEN IF THE AN
REQUESTS. THE INVESTIGATION
WILL OCCUR IT'S NOT OPTIONAL.
IT IS ALSO A CHANGES WHO
REQUESTS SO RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE
A SURE OF FIFTY EIGHT THAT OUR
CONSTITUTIONALOFFICERS THAT
ARE ELECTED TO THE RESPONSIBLE
TO THE VOTERS TO DO WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S BEST IN. THEY WOULD THEN
GIVE IT TO THE ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ALSO A CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER. AND THERE'S ALSO THE
GRAND JURY OF EACH COUNTY
THAT'S AVAILABLE AND THEN IT
GETS BABY PUSHED UP TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. SO THE CHANGE
IS IT NOW IS REQUIRED TO GO TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OR
WHATEVER OTHER MODEL- WHO WE
SELECT SO I AM CURIOUS- IN
CITIES THE CITY MANAGER'S CITY
COUNCIL DAYS. AND CONTROL THE
POLICE CHIEF SO I CAN SEE WHY
THEY WOULD HAVE AUTHORITY TO
BRING IT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. COUNTIES YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT THE INTERESTING
DILEMMA OF AN ELECTED SHERIFF
ANALECTA BOARD OF SUPERVISORS-
AND SO THERE'S JUST SOME ISSUES
THERE ARE I'M JUST WONDERING.
OUR IF COUNTY SHE BE X. FROM
YOUR BILL. WELL IN IN SOME
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE
SACRAMENTO IN A LARGE PART OF
L. A. COUNTY. THIS THE SHERIFF
THE COUNTY IS THE CITY IT'S THE
IT'S THE GOVERNING BODY IN IN
THESE ON A CORPORATE AREAS
WHERE THAT. IT'S NOT LIKE THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH AND
SIDE OF ORANGE COUNTY CITY
THEY'LL GROW WITH YOU
SACRAMENTO LABIALS LARGE AREAS
WHERE YOU KNOW IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT. SO I THINK
THAT'S THE- THAT'S THE LOGIC
THERE. AND I'M JUST CURIOUS
SINCE WE IN THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO. WHO WERE YOU
SATISFIED WITH THE AG'S
INVESTIGATION OF THE STEPHON
CLARK. I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
EXTREMELY HELPFUL SOME WEREN'T
PLEASED WITH THE OUTCOME- THE
LAST YEAR'S EIGHT AB THREE
NINETY TWO WILL DETERMINE THE
JUSTIFICATION OF FORCE IN THE
FUTURE WHETHER IT'S- OKAY OR
NOT OKAY AS FAR AS THAT
APPROVED FOR USE OF DEADLY
FORCE BUT BUT HAVING- YOU KNOW
THAT AN INDEPENDENT UMPIRE
CALLING BALLS AND STRIKES IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S SO EMOTIONAL IN THE
COMMUNITY LIKE WE'VE HEARD FROM
ABOUT. A I'M SURE YOUR
COLLEAGUES MISTER DODD IN OUR
CALLING THIS GRAYSON WHAT'S YOU
ALL ABOUT IT IT'S- IN OUR OUR
WITNESS ABOUT IT. THEY DO NOT
WANT THE LOCAL DISTRIBUTOR OR
THE LOW POLICE TO AND
INVESTIGATION THEY THEY WANT
THIS THIRD PARTY. INDEPENDENT
PIECE AND SO. IT IS OKAY AND
CAN RARE CASES WHERE THERE HAS
BEEN THE REQUEST IT'S COME UP
AND IT HAS BEEN HELPFUL. BUT
IT'S THE- EXCEPTION NOT THE
NORM. AND UNFORTUNATELY- THE
DEBT TURNING GENERAL'S OFFICE
ROOM ROUTINELY SAYS SAYS NOTE
THESE REQUESTS AND SO. OUR
PROCESS WOULD SET UP AND SAY
IF. THAT SHOULD SHERIFF OF
ORANGE COUNTY NEAR POLICE CHIEF
OF. NORTH LOCAL THERE. ASKED
THIS INDEPENDENT. THE STATE
PROSECUTOR. COULD NOT SAY NOW.
HELLO I HAD TO PLAY OF SETTING
UP AN OFF HAVE BEEN REVIEW WHEN
I WAS COUNTIES WHO. TO DO WITH
OUR SHARE YOUR WORK ON. A
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE INNOCENT
VEIN IN SO EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
IT'S INTERESTING TERROR. WAS
SORT OF IN A ACT CAME OUT OF
THE L. A. BY MIKE G. AND SHOULD
NOT GO. A SO ARE CURIOUS AT I
DIDN'T HAVE A TOWARD THE SEE IT
ALTHOUGH CENTER RITUALS OF
PROMOTE WITH THE VETERAN TO BUY
WHAT IS THIS MODEL CANAL THAT
JUST A WEEK AGO. IT GOOD COULD
YOU JUST HELP ME AND MAYBE EVER
ANYBODY THAT'S WHY. THAT HAS
HEARD OF THE MODEL A YOU WHAT
THE IS I DON'T KNOW BY THE
DETAIL OF THAT YOU. CANAL ONE
BAD KNOW THAT THEIR FIVE STATE.
AND THE PER. IS VERY CLEAR I.
THEY TAKE ALL. OF THE CAL OF
THE DEADLY FOR INTO. IN THOSE
STATES AND SOME OF THE R. SUM.
CONNECTICUT BY THE SIDE OF LA
IN ORANGE COMBINED. WISCONSIN
STEP THREE POINT FIVE MILLION.
TO THE LARGER OURS BUT ILLINOIS
IN THE- AND IT HOW THE AS WELL
AS WELL AS THE- AND SO. IT
MODELS BUT THE PREMISE. IS IT'S
THAT THE LAW THIS ATTORNEY HAS
JUST AT TIME. BEING CREDIBLE
WITH INVESTIGATION BECAUSE HOW
THEY IN FOR A- THEY GET THE
AWAY IN DORTMUND THIS. ENDORSED
BY. THEY'RE GOOD THEY'RE
INVESTIGATE SOMEONE THAT THEY
KNEW AND WITH THEIR- THEM. IN
THE CASE. SO IT JUST BREED.
DISTRUST AND SO I THAT'S WHY
SEEN. UP PROCESS. ACROSS THE
NAY SO YOU KNOW. THIS ONE.
THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO GO
DOING THAT. THREE FIVE CAN IT
BE. DIFFERENT WHAT. IN EVERY SO
AN ATTORNEY HAS THE TO INVEST
ALONG FOR H. HOWEVER THERE ARE
SO STATES THAT'S- THAT. TYPE
INCIDENTS TYPES OF SHOOTING
WILL BE IN. THE VERY IN IN SOME
STAY IT IS THE ATTORNEY. AND
OTHERS IT IS A SEPARATELY
ENTITY AND THE CONNECTICUT LAW
THAT JUST PASSED. WAS THEY GAVE
THAT AUTHORITY. TO EIGHT TO BE
ESTABLISHED SEPARATE
PROSECUTING ANTI NOT TO THEIR
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THERE WAS
ONLY JUST PASSED SO WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW. WHETHER IT BUILDS
TRUST YOUR IS FAIR OR
INDEPENDENCE BUT BUILT
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT THEIR HI CAN'T RECALL RIGHT
NOW BUT THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
OTHER STATES THAT DO HAVE.
ENTITIES ALREADY THAT ARE NOT
HERE TURNING GENERAL'S BUT I
DON'T HAVE DATA ON DOES. I'LL
DO A LITTLE MORE RESEARCH MY
LAST QUESTION MANAGERS JUST
COSTS ARE YOU TO MAKE YOUR CASE
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WELL THIS IS PURSUANT TO BEING
FUNDED IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
WE'RE WE'RE ENGAGING WITH THE
GOVERNOR HE'S EXTREMELY
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE. WE'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT HE LIKES THE
NOTION OF HAVING INDEPENDENT
DESTINATIONS FOR DEADLY FORCE
INCIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA LIKE
THESE FIVE OTHER STATES HAVE
BEEN DOING. YOU WERE WE'RE
SORTING THAT OUT YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE POLICY COMMITTEE AND
GREAT DEBATE TODAY AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE STILL. YOU KNOW WORKING
OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES AYE
AYE AYE REALLY ADMIT BUT WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS IS A OF
PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA. NOTE IF
IT'S IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE THEY HAVE A BIG BUDGET
OF A BILLION DOLLARS PLUS- YOU
KNOW IF POTENTIALLY THIS COULD
BE MORE. READY WITHIN THOSE
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
THERE. OR THAT THIS COULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR OUR OUR DECK OUR
BUDGET PROCESS NEXT YEAR AND I
KNOW WE HAVE. LIMITATIONS
WITHIN THEIR THAT COVER
NINETEEN REALITY- BUT- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ENGAGING
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THEY ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
THIS IN THIS PROPOSAL. SENATE
MITCHELL JUST SAID THANKS SORRY
ABOUT YOUR- CENTER. I THINK YOU
BETTER CHAIR AHEAD YOU CAN MAKE
IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE DONT KNOW
PLEASE IF YOU ARE A GOING ON
NOTHING I IS ON HIS THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL. AND I WANT TO SEE
HOW BIRTHDAY TO THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU DID. THE YOU KNOW
FOCUSED ON THE COST HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE- BUT BUT I ALSO
REALIZE THAT THE AMENDMENTS-
EXPAND QUITE FRANKLY. THE
SCULPINS FIGURE OF THE RICH
ORIGINAL COMMITTEE UP OVER AND
REGIONAL BE ALSO I JUST WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THE NEW
LANGUAGE IN MY EFFORT TO KIND
OF GRAPPLE WITH IT AND KIND OF
FIGURE IT OUT. TO HAVE HEARD
THE OPPOSITION I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOU. SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BE- EIGHT EIGHT
BILL HOPEFULLY TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY- IN PROCESS AND
UNDER CONSIDERATION- BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I WAS
ABLE TO JUST SHARE KIND OF MY
PERSPECTIVE IN. AN AND HOPING
THAT WE DON'T SET OURSELVES UP
FOR. A PROLONGED. PROCESS AND
ALSO THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
FULLY CONTROL IF WE'RE NOT
CLEAR ABOUT THE WHO AND THE
WHAT AND MAKE IT YOU KNOW
CONTENT UPON A- BUDGET PRICE
PROCESS THAT THAT TAKES. US OUT
OF THE FINAL ANALYSIS TO SOME
DEGREE IN ALL FAIRNESS- SIZE
ONE TO MAKE SURE I SAID THAT
BUT I'M ON THE BILL AT THIS
POINT- AND HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
BE PLUGGED IN TO. THE CHANGES
AS THEY CONTINUE TO DEVELOP.
JUST ONE FOR. THE REJECTION
YEAH I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
TOO BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO
THIS DISCUSSION ALONG BUT I'D
SAY THIS THIS BILL AND THE
WHOLE PROCESS RIGHT NOW THE-
WE'RE TWO WEEKS FROM THE END OF
SESSION AND WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE INTO. A IT'S A
LITTLE UNSETTLING- THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE- I WOULD HAVE
TO BEG TO DIFFER WITH SOME OF
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS WHO
HAVE- SPOKEN UP HERE IF YOU
DON'T LIKE WHAT THE PROPOSED
SOLUTION BETTER OFFER SOMETHING
YOURSELVES- THE BECAUSE- I
THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT
THERE IS AT LEAST THE
PERCEPTION IF NOT A REALITY
THAT THERE ARE TOO MANY OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS AND THAT
THEY'RE NOT PROPERLY
INVESTIGATED AND ADDRESSED AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. NOT QUITE
SURE I'M TOTALLY UNDERSTANDING
AND I'M WILL REFLECT ON THIS A
LITTLE BIT MORE THESE
AMENDMENTS OBVIOUSLY MORE CLEAR
TO THE PEOPLE'S IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION FROM HOPE TO WE GET
THAT CLARITY BEFORE THE BILL
COMES BEFORE US UP THE FLOOR.
BUT IF IT DOES AND I'M A PRE
YOUR EFFORTS BOB AGAIN LIKE TO
INVITE. OTHER WHO OPPOSE THIS
NOTION OF INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS- HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE FRANKLY
DON'T TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT TO-
MONITOR AND TO REGULATE THEIR
OWN AND I THINK THAT THERE IS
SOME. LEGITIMATE REASON WHY-
BUT TO AND THAT'S WHY I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
DOES TRY TO MOVE THAT BALL
FORWARD INTO A MORE
INDEPENDENT- ENTITY THAT
DOESN'T HAVE ITS- OWN INTEREST
IN THE OUTCOME. BUT WE DID THIS
PREVIOUSLY- IN THE AREA OF- OUR
SHERIFFS WERE ALSO THE-
CORNERS. AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMING TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION HERE. AND
THE REALITIES OF THE PUBLIC'S
PERSPECTIVE. M. HEALTH TO UP.
IN TRYING TO LEAVE A- OF THOSE
ALLEGED CONCERNS. I WILL SEND
BUT I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE THE MOMENT SO
THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MANAGER I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS EFFORT THIS
IS HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU
INTRODUCED THE VERSIONS
BELASYSE A THIRD THIRD TIME. SO
EVEN THOUGH- YOU KNOW HE'S
IMPORTANCE AS TERMS OF CONTACTS
YES THIS IS AN ABBREVIATED
SESSION. READING CHALLENGES
WITH A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
BILLS ON WORK THAT WE NEED TO
DO. AND SO I KNOW BETWEEN NOW
AND YOU KNOW PRESUMABLY. NEXT
WEEK POLLS DO MORE WORK ON THIS
AND SINCE IT HAS TO BE FUNDED
ANYWAY. YOU KNOW THERE CAN ALSO
BE YOU KNOW CLEANUP'S NEXT YEAR
AS WELL. BUT I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS
NOT A NEW. IDEA OF THE AUTHOR
HAS BEEN RAISING THIS ISSUE THE
BILL'S GONNA BE TOTALLY FOR A
DIET OR WHAT WASN'T SUCCESSFUL.
I'M SORRY COMMEND YOU FOR
KEEPING AT AT. AND I SINGLE
SPECIALLY NOW THIS YEAR IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MAKE A
STRONG STATEMENT. ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INDEPENDENCE
IN THESE- INVESTIGATIONS. YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S AN- PACKAGE
EVERY INTO. FOR FIVE DAYS.
INVESTIGATIONS TO BE
INDEPENDENT AND TO BE
PERCEIVED. AS INDEPENDENT. I
INCLUDING THE OFFICERS BECAUSE
OF AN OFFICER- FOR DECISIONS
MAY NOT TO CHARGE TO EXONERATE
THE OFFICER. IT'S GONNA YOU
KNOW HAVING THE COMMUNITY HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT IT WAS A REAL
INVESTIGATION INDEPENDENT-
INVESTIGATION THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR EVERYONE FOR THE
COMMUNITY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE FAMILY AND THE SURVIVORS
IMPORTANT FOR. THE OFFICER WHO
IS INVOLVED IT'S IN EVERYONE'S
INTEREST. FOR THERE TO BE
UNIVERSAL CONFIDENCE OF THIS
THESE INVESTIGATIONS ARE BEING
DONE INDEPENDENTLY AND WELL. I
NOTICED SOME MORE WORK TO DO
AND FRANKLY PARKING TO BE MORE
WORK TO DO NEXT YEAR-BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
MAKE A STATEMENT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THIRTY THREE FOUR FIVE S.
FOR YOUR CLOTHES LET ME JUST.
ADD WHAT I HOPE IS SOME
CLARIFICATIONS SOUGHT. D. THE
BILL. IF IT IS SIGNED INTO LAW
DOES IMMEDIATELY GOING TO
AFFECT THE END BECAUSE WE HAVE
A STATE PROSECUTOR AND THAT IS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SO IT DOES
IMMEDIATELY GOING TO AFFECT.
THE DIFFERENCE THE THING THAT
THE BILL FUNDAMENTALLY DOES
THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
STATUS QUO THE STATUS QUO RIGHT
NOW. OUR STATE PROSECUTOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS THE RIGHT
TO INVESTIGATE ANY SHOOTING.
AND RIGHT NOW IT JURISDICTION
CAN ASK THEM TO AS WE HAVE
OBSERVED THEY HAPPEN. IN SOME
CASES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
SAID NO. AND I'M NOT REFERRING
LET ME BACK UP I'M NOT TRYING
TO PERSONALIZE THIS TO A
CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL IF WE
LOOK T ALL ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
FOR THE LAST AT LEAST MYERS
RATIONS TWENTY YEARS. THEY
HAVE. THOSE OFFICES HAVE NOT
WANTED TO BE INVOLVED IN
INVESTIGATING SUCH SHOOTINGS.
THEY HAVE TENDED NOT TO. WHERE
THEY HAVE. AND TEY'VE TENDED
NOT TO RESPOND POSITIVELY TO
WHEN THEY ARE ASKED. SO THE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE AT THIS
BILL DOES IS REQUIRES
INVESTIGATIONS. FOR ALL OF
THOSE DEATHS THAT ARE UNARMED
PEOPLE. AND THEN ALLOWS
REQUIRES INVESTIGATION NOT JUST
ALLOWS REQUIRES INVESTIGATIONS
IF THE D. A. THE SHERIFF OR THE
GOVERNING BODY ASKS THE DA THE
SHERIFF STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY FOR THE GOVERNING BODY
SO NOT ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASKS SO THOSE ARE THE
FUNDAMENTAL POLICY DIFFERENCES
THAT THIS BILL MAKES. AND THOSE
IF WERE TO BE SIGNED INTO LAW
GO INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
WHERE OBVIOUSLY A BUDGET QUICK
COMES INTO PLAY IS IF. THERE
IS. D. DESIRE TO ESTABLISH WELL
FIRST. IF THE OFFICE IF THE
AG'S OFFICE OBVIOUSLY WILL COME
BACK IN EDUCATE. THEY WILL NEED
X. AMOUNT OF STAFF IN UP TO
APPROPRIATELY IMPLEMENT THE
BILL'S AS DESIGNED OR IF THERE
IS THE DESIRE TO ESTABLISH A
INDEPENDENT OFFICE. SEPARATE
FROM THE AG'S AND THE IF THE
BILL WERE DESIGNED TO FROM DAY
ONE SET UP AN INDEPENDENT
OFFICE THAT WOULD TAKE TIME AND
THEN THERE WOULD BE OTHER
PROVISIONS IN EFFECT WOULD NOT
GO INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE THEY WOULD TAKE THE
TIME TO ESTABLISH THAT
INDEPENDENT DID YOU STARK SO AT
LEAST IF THERE IS THE CHOICE TO
SET UP THE INDEPENDENT ENTITY
THERE'S AT LEAST PROVISION FOR
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE INTERIM
IF THERE ARE SUCH SHOOTINGS IN
THAT IMPROVE. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR VACATION SINGLE
LITTLE CONFUSION THAT WHEN A
BILL GOES WHEN A BILL BECOMES
LAW IF IN THE CASE IT DOES IT
ISN'T AFFECTING EVEN THOUGH IN
THE- NOT BEEN. YET MATE CENTER
SO DO YOU WANT HAS BUDGET
YOU'RE A FEW FIVE THERE'S A
CLEAR IF THERE'S A TICKET WAS
IN THEIR OWN NOT A OKAY HE HE.
YEAH ABOUT THAT BUT BUT IN IN
YOUR- BEAR IN IN IN IN IN IN
THAT. IN YOUR MIND MADAM. WHO
WOULD THEN MAKE THE DECISION IF
AN INDEPENDENT ENTITY WHAT WERE
TO BE SET UP THAT THAT'S WHERE
I'M NOT CLEAR IF THAT'S THAT'S
MY POINT ABOUT- I DON'T WEEK IN
RIGHT THE BODY OF LAW WE PASS
MAKE THE DECLARE TAKE THAT THE
ORIGINAL BILL. REFERENCE THE
BOMB ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL YES SO IN YOUR
MIND THE SCENARIO YOU JUST PAY
FOR US WHO WOULD MAKE THAT
DECISION. SO D. R. INTO- THE- I
DON'T MEAN TO BE TO A- I GUESS
I WOULD POSE IT IS THAT. THE
WAY THE BILL IS WRITTEN IT
WOULD NOT REQUIRE A STATUTE
CHANGE. FOR SUCH AN
ESTABLISHMENT SO IF FOR EXAMPLE
THE LEGISLATURE WAS THE ENTITY
THAT. TWENTY FIVE THAT MMHM
THEN AT LEAST WOULDN'T HAVE TO
CHANGE ITS STATUTE BUT
CERTAINLY IT WOULD HAVE TO. YES
OKAY THIRD SAYS THAT HELP. OKAY.
SENATOR MOORLACH HAS BEEN A
CLARIFICATION AND I'M SURE YOU
SAID IT COMES EFFECTIVE
IMMEDIATELY AND WELL WHEN AT.
THE NORMAL TIME OF IF THE BILL
IS SIGNED INTO LAW IT WOULD BE
JANUARY FIRST THANK YOU
MEASURES CELL. BUSINESS AND
ANYTHING LOWER TAKE A LOOK BACK
YEAH. OKAY PART OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY ME CLOSE YES
THANK YOU I THINK A LOT OF YOU
HELP ME CLOSE IN YOUR IN YOUR
FINAL COMMENTS- TRIED TO PRE
BRIEF IN MY CLASS. THERE HAVE
FLOYD WAS LAST YEAR MY CAN.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT CRY FOR
COMMONSENSE POLICE REFORM AND
SOME TIMES REALLY AGGRESSIVE
POLICE REFORM THIS ONE I THINK
IS WHAT SETS IS IT'S REALLY NOT
THAT COMPLICATED THAT'S WHY YOU
SEE. FOR SUPPLY. PEACEABLE
TALKING IF YOU LOOK AS FAR AS
THE PEOPLE TALKING IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION A LOT OF
COMMENTS TODAY RIGHT AND THEY
DID THAT THAT THAT CONCLUSION
IS THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS JUST
DISTRUST THE LOCAL LEVEL AND-
WE'RE WORKING REALLY HARD TO
MAKE. THANK DONE THAT THE
NOTION THAT. THE SENDER
JACKSON'S IS TRUE NOBODY TRUSTS
WHEN POLICE POLICE THE- IS COME
SENSE AND SO BRING IN ABOUT. A
DEFINED APPROACH FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR ARTS LEADS
STATE PROSECUTOR WHETHER IT'S-
TURNING GENERAL OR SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO HAVE A HAVE A ROLE
IN THAT IS WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN CALIFORNIA TO
BRING ABOUT MORE PUBLIC TRUST
IN OUR POLICING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND CONTINUE TO
WITH WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR WE GO
TO THE PURPOSE COMMITTEE
PROCESS BUT I REALLY THAT. THE
IS THINK THIS COVER NINETEEN
TRY PROCESSES COMPLICATED BUT
THE TIME IS RIGHT TO DO THIS
NOW ARE WANTING THIS TO HAPPEN.
AND WITH THAT I ASK THE ARRIVAL
THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- YES THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENATOR MITCHELL. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL IT IS AGAIN PLEASE
STATE THE MOTION AB FIFTEEN NOW
SIX TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER FIVE IN
OUR AYE MORLOCK AYE MOORLACH
AYE BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON JACKSON NINE ACCENT AYE
MITCHELL. MITCHELL I'M MORALE
WIENER WIENER ON. SIX TWO ZERO
BILLS THREE FIVE WE HAVE A
FINAL BILL THANK YOU HAVE A-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING. IF. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
COMMITTEE AND- NOTING THAT IT'S
YOUR BIRTHDAY I WILL SPARE THE
THIRTY MINUTE PRESENTATION. AND
GO TO THE PREVIOUS ONE HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MANAGER. FOR SOMEONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL- AS YOU KNOW YOU'VE
PASSED THIS BILL IN THE PAST BY
THIS COMMITTEE BUT BIGGER YOUR
STRONG ENGAGEMENT THIS YEAR
OPTICALLY THE COLLABORATION
WITH THE BRADY CAMPAIGN AND
ADDS MADE THIS BILL- A MUCH
STRONGER BILL AND ONE THAT AND
ONE THAT SEEMS TO DO. AT TO
PRESERVE THAT THAT THOSE FARMS
OR STAYED- STAYED WHERE THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO NOT ACTUALLY
END UP IN PRIVATE HANDS. THIS
BILL WILL TEND TO CLEAN UP SOME
AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW THAT
AUTHORIZED SPECIFIC STATE
AGENCIES. ARE THEY HAVE FARMS
AND NO LONGER LISTED ON THE
DOJ'S- ROSTRUM HANDGUNS THE
BILL'S REALLY TECHNICAL IN
NATURE- THERE'S A MENTION YOU
SAW LAST YEAR WITH THE REG
JONES SAWYER- BUT HE CARED A
VERSION OF THIS AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR STRONG ENGAGEMENT. AND
HAVING. TO PROTECT- I HAVE BEEN
PROTECTIONS IN THEIR THAT WORN
IN THE PAST AND I REALLY DO
MEAN THAT IT'S- MADE A MUCH
STRONGER BILL. AND WHEN WE CAN
STAND BY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL AND WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
WILL ALSO BE BRIEF MENTOR.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THAT LEAD
WITNESS. FILLETED WITNESS ON
THE LINE MODERATOR. THE HEY
NEVER GOT ON M. I'M SURE MEMBER
SHANE LEVINE AMERICA CHANGE A
GOOD. GOOD AFTERNOON EVENING
BUT WE'RE THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL THIS BILL THE FACT WE-
FINAL CLEANUP OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA FROM FOUR YEARS AGO- A
LOT OF CONVERSATION AND WORK
ONE IN THE BILL THE LAST FEW
WEEKS WE'VE AGREED TO A NUMBER
OF SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS OF
THE PARTY CAMPAIGN THAT
FRANKLY. WE'RE VERY PROUD TO
ACCEPT- TO MAKE THIS BETTER
BILL STRONGER BILL- AND THAT
CLOSES LOOPHOLES ALSO WITH THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MODERATOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
STROLL SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE UP NOW AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT ONE AND THEN
THERE ARE NOW. AT THE REMINDER
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE OKAY LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ON NOW AGAIN TO UPHOLD ONE AND
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO UPHOLD
THE LAW AND THEN ZERO NOW. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE AND I'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. MODERATOR.
NINE YES WE DO HAVE TO IN A
QUEUE AT ALL BE JUST A MOMENT
WHY THEY GATHER THE NUMBERS FOR
THEM. SPONSOR MORE LIKE PHILIP
RIVERS. OKAY GO AHEAD GO AHEAD
MOTOR WE DO HAVE A LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MATTHEW
SUCKLING ON BEHALF OF THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING MY THANK
YOU TO PROVIDE SUPPORT BT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOUTHANK YOU. BYE
MODERATOR NEXT. AND THEN WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE AND THEN I'LL BE
JUST A SECOND. BOB MACK BOTTOM
LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD EVENING REBEKAH
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF BRADY
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE I
WANTED TO QUICKLY STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT WE HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION DUE TO THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS AND CHANGE OUR
POSITION TO NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
MANY THANKS TO THE CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEDIA NOT HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY OF.
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THE SCHOOL HAD LOTS OF THE BILL
WE HAVE A MOTION. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YEAH WE
DID I ASK FOR OPPOSITION AND
THE LAST CALLERS HAD REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION RIGHT OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO YOU
MAY CLOSE I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR STRONG
ENGAGEMENT IN THIS AND HELPING
TO MAKE THIS A MUCH STRONGER
BILL THANK YOU. I DO MEAN THAT.
ARE YOU ARE WELCOME. WE HAVE A
MOTION- IN THE OF A MOTION
WOULD BE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO.
NO SAGAN. POCKETS MOMENTS ARE
ALREADY IN THE BILL- SO WE
MANAGE PROCESS THEM ALL RIGHT
SO IT'S JUST DO PASS AND IS IT
TO APPROACH HER TO THE FLOOR.
YOU PASSED PROBES ARE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER BY IN
OUR AYE MOORLACH MOORLACH AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE. JAROCIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SON THIAGO WE
NEED TO AND YOU KNOW YOU'LL
NEED ENOUGH HER YOU'LL NEED ON
THE ROAD WITH THE ALL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE
ANOTHER MEMBER TO RETURN I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SO I
LIKE THAT. THANK YOU.
FOR
MEMBER STAT ON. MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL. WINNER. I KNOW WIENER
NOW. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE THE
THEIR BILL IS FOR ONE. AND.
THERE WILL SEE IF WE HAVE ONE
MORE MEMBER WE'LL SEE IF SHE
WANTS TO RETURN OR.
AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE WE'RE GONNA NOW
CLOSE THE BILL OUT IT HAS FOR
YES ONE NO. IT PASSES AND WITH
THAT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WILL ADJOURN.